yeah I definitely feel like there is a
high Beauty standard in the UK
um yeah that's my opinion okay what do
you think what are beauty standards for
me I okay I'm gonna say that it does
come from within however I'd be lying if
I would say that you don't look at
Beauty like you can tell in the UK right
like who is attractive and who isn't you
just know that so to say that it comes
from within I think yes this that's the
general statement for anyone to make
because nobody wants to sound like oh
they're being shallow but realistically
speaking the majority of society are
shallow you do look at people and what
they look like yeah okay so you would
say it's based on looks yeah it is what
what metrics would you use to measure
someone's Beauty
um
for me personally
um is it men or women are women women
um it would for me I look at a woman's
if I can strip back everything in terms
of like the makeup the hair the nails
and to me I can see her as beautiful
then she's beautiful but that's just me
again my preference okay yeah uh what do
you think Troy what are beauty standards
I mean look I think it's entirely
physical to be honest I don't want to
sound cynical here but I think that's
what people look at I think it's nice to
say it's from within and there's yeah
sure I mean there's some truth in that
but I think let's let's be let's be real
the dating Marketplace it's a kind of a
jungle out there right what are people
looking at they're looking at the
Aesthetics right they're looking at the
surface now that's not to say that you
meet somebody and maybe they have a
really obnoxious personality and you
think actually I'm put off from that or
they've got something about them that's
really great and you guys click and that
adds something to it 100 that's that's
definitely true but let's let's be
honest right it's a surface level thing
there are there are aesthetic standards
and that's what people mean when they're
talking about beauty
I don't think the standards are
particularly high in the UK but that's
just yeah
that's just me though guys sorry
um
for men as well for men as well for men
as well
you get humbled real quick
well Miami but also like Latin America
I'm in Eastern Europe all those places
oh yeah yeah I went to a wedding in
Germany it was like all the girls were
like literally stunning yeah
um
okay what do you think yeah I do agree I
feel like it is based on how a woman
looks I feel like as she mentioned if a
woman's got her nails done hair done
you've got yourself together men do like
that it is you know quite obvious as
well a man especially a regular man in
the UK I don't feel like they would go
for just a basic looking woman yeah they
would go for a woman who's you know got
themselves put together got their nails
done they look good and yeah I don't
really agree when they said that it's
within it's just my opinion anyways I
feel like if someone looks good then
that's what attracts attracts men as
well yeah what do you think
um I agree to an extent um
I definitely feel as though beauty is an
attraction I feel like if someone's
attracted to you they're gonna think
you're beautiful regardless however I do
not agree that
um just because you're well done up that
then
implicates that you're beautiful you
know I don't have no makeup on now I'm
very much beautiful
um I don't need makeup to Define my
beauty
um I think
um yeah I don't even go to find my
beauty
however you know I do definitely feel
like
you have to be attracted to someone in
order for you to think that they are
beautiful
do you guys think that beauty standards
are higher we're higher 100 years ago or
today
definitely today today
definitely today is there anyone that
thinks they were higher 100 years ago
anyone no because if you look back at
old black and white photographs from the
Victorian era and then you look at you
just do a scroll through Instagram now I
mean I mean like it's night and day in
terms of in terms of hotness and I think
that's down to a number of things it's
like to do with nutrition it's to do
with Fitness it's to do with the fact
that we're all encouraged to work out
now uh make up you know clothing there's
so many different things bits of surgery
and procedures and stuff I mean there's
so many different things that come into
it so I think yeah definitely overall
you know people are more aesthetically
pleasing now it was probably only the
rich people that were super hot back in
there that's what I was going to say I
was gonna say I thought like
um things are more accessible now so
yeah like makeup like it's you know less
I don't know about pricing but I feel
like surgery is more accessible to
people and stuff like yeah and I feel
like that's probably why the standards
are a little bit higher yeah do women
respond when beauty standards go higher
yeah yeah and how how do we respond
typically
we followed the trend yeah
we follow the trend what trends so like
the BBL Trend that's happening at the
moment I feel like it's going down now
but um yeah I guess we just followed the
trend like um what else is it like
makeup yeah
lip fillers
now yeah I disagree a little bit because
I don't follow like all the latest
trends all the time sometimes it's
overwhelming to me so I try to do what
is best for me and obviously we live in
this Society where social media is like
it's everything so everyone is bombarded
with all these images but that doesn't
mean that I'm gonna follow any single
trend is up there because it's
overwhelming to me so
um does beauty standards include weight
yes to an extent I think yeah yeah
does anyone think it doesn't yeah I
don't think so anymore I I don't think
so anymore I feel like
um I feel like all shapes and sizes
right now I might be wrong I accepted so
um I just feel like for me personally
it's based on how well how well you keep
yourself and how put together you look
not about your size that's just me
personally do you think men think the
same thing yeah it doesn't I actually
think so actually yeah
I think it depends yeah
no but in general so we could talk about
in general would you say men care or
they don't care about women who care
hence why girls are out here doing bbls
is BBL the bum thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah
do you think women are more put together
today than 100 years ago definitely yeah
definitely
you look at some some of these old
pictures though seriously like these
Dusty old like photographs sometimes you
see I mean they're not looking good you
know the the ladies weren't representing
back then you know what I mean but then
back then it might have been a thing
that's how they were meant to look yeah
it's true it's true yeah those days were
like oh yeah they're beautiful yeah yeah
that's true that's true look at them now
but back then yeah she was hot yeah
it was more natural back in the days it
was like you know beauty is like in
today's like oh you need to be the
perfect the perfect man and I don't
think they cared much of us but don't
you think the one thing I've observed
like here and also in the states a
little bit as well is that a lot of
there's a seems to be this fashion now
for women wearing quite baggy clothes
have you noticed like if you go to a
shopping mall or something like that
during the daytime a lot of the women
are wearing like quite baggy jeans quite
baggy and and maybe less makeup and
stuff which sort of goes counter to that
Instagram thing in a way doesn't it
because I think just looking around the
streets I think a lot of women are
dressing up sort of a bit less slowly
during the daytime here but then if you
go to say Poland or if you go to Ukraine
or something or prior to the you know
the war
um you would see a very different sort
of story so I think in the west it feels
like um
I'd always say standards are falling but
it seems like a more casualness is sort
of accepted into the women because I see
more yoga pants and sweat I would say I
see more yoga pants and sweats than I
did 20 like 10 years ago let's say when
I was like 26 when I was 16. you know it
was like I don't know because you guys
are different about yoga pants a little
bit but in the US they're like super
common but I remember it was like a
fight on Facebook about if yoga pants
were acceptable in public
I don't know if you guys have that here
if that was just an American fight
I was in I was in LA recently and I saw
there was a lot of yoga pants going on
down in sort of um Venice and Venice
Beach and like places like that yeah so
my question is if beauty standards are
higher and women respond to beauty
standards why are women more overweight
today and we dress up less
laughs
is that a stats that you have by any
jobs yeah in the 90s and the 90s and the
90 and the 19 I mean there's no stat on
dressing up that's just anecdotal but
when it comes to weight only 10 of women
were overweight in the 40s were 60 of
women in the UK are overweight
70 in America you gotta remember back in
the olden days they had this thing where
they used to wear corsets in order to
line their bodies so they had this that
was their Trend you know that isn't the
trend here so you've got to understand
that as times as Society changes so does
the trends I guess no yeah but my
question is more like if women respond
to beauty standards and women actually
cared about beauty standards like why
are we more overweight and we dress up
less because of the food that we eat
right but that kind of indicates that we
don't care as much as we say we do like
because we're supposed to be under this
immense pressure right from society but
it doesn't seem like our looks are
getting better as a whole I think again
if you compare to other societies
because like before the you know in the
west yeah but just yeah just just as a
Counterpoint though so when like in 2021
where I was in spent quite a lot of time
in in Russia and then and then also in
Ukraine prior to what's happening now
and um it is a very different story
though you do get a lot of women who are
very elegant they're still wearing you
know
maybe peels slightly less during the
daytime but you know what I mean very
very elegant wearing dresses all the
time but very very feminine in a way
that you don't see so much here and I
think that's got something to do with
feminism to be honest or at least the
the tide of
because Society is telling women you
don't have to make why you don't have to
make an effort for it sounds very crude
but you don't have to make an effort for
men right because why should you right
because you are you're enough in
yourself okay
um and and I think that's got something
to do with it to be honest you know I
don't think Society is and I'm not
saying Society should be compelling
women to do that but I don't think it is
whereas I think in some of those other
countries that are arguably a little bit
more patriarchal let's say
um there is still that pressure and so
women are dressing up more and also they
have to compete with one another because
otherwise if you're the the girl who's
you know just just not not bothering and
everyone else is then you're gonna kind
of get left to the side aren't you
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and
with ties on
editor sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible